[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me voilà face peut-être à ce qui nous
arrive en ce moment dans le monde à
savoir ce qu'on peut appeler un
événement cet événement s'est depuis
trois semaines ce que nous n'imaginions
pas possible ce que nous n'avions pas
attendu et en même temps ce qu'on
espérait à savoir le fait non pas que
notre parole soit libéré mais que nous
ayons pris la parole je tiens absolument
à faire la distinction
j'abandonne le fait qu'on pense qu'on a
libéré outre les femmes ont libéré leur
parole elles ont pris la parole
donc en prenant la parole c'est un
événement est pour moi c'est important
alors juste pour me situer parce que
c'est nécessaire ce soir j'ai fait des
études de philosophie et conduit un
parcours de chercheur en philosophie sur
cette question de l'égalité des sexes et
j'ai fait mes études à un moment où
juste au moment de 68 et de la naissance
du mlf se posait la question de savoir
quel est l émancipation des femmes
j'ai rien trouvé dans mes études de
philosophie et ce manque ce blanc j'ai
passé ma vie à essayer finalement de
construire quelque chose pour le rendre
intelligible et intelligent alors ça
veut dire que au fond j'ai deux
propositions à vous faire ce soir la
première c'est de dire nous assistons à
un évènement c'est-à-dire à quelque
chose qui rentre dans l'histoire il ya
quinze jours encore quand j'ai des
interlocuteurs divers et variés il me
disait mais c'est de l'hystérie ou c
c'est de la dénonciation etc etc je leur
disais non il se passe quelque chose je
pense qu'il se passe quelque chose en ce
moment ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises
ce soir et ça veut dire que ce qui
importe s'il tient pour moi en une
phrase c'est que les sexes font
l'histoire
mettez genre si vous voulez vous mettez
ce que vous voulez mais je dis
simplement l'histoire est sexuée d'une
part et les sexes au fond l'histoire
nous ne sommes pas en dehors de
l'histoire donc que peut être cet
événement et que représente-t-il par
rapport à l'histoire de l'émancipation
des femmes puisque comme vous venez de
l'entendre
au fond je ne travaille pas sur
l'analyse de la domination qui a été
plusieurs fois évoquée ce soir mais
plutôt comment on construit une pensée
de l'émancipation est là ce que je
remarque cette 21ème siècle provoque
annonce est en train de vivre peut-être
une rupture
alors quelle rupture pas le progrès est
enfin arrivé
pas la joie d'une subversion inattendu
non quelque chose de plus lié à
l'histoire de la démocratie qui nous
habite depuis deux ou trois siècles
trois siècles si on pense à la pensée de
la démocratie de siècle si on pense aux
après révolution est donc au xixème et
xxème siècles et ce qui s'est passé
c'est un processus de démocratie
exclusivement partir d'un clusif
maintenant mais on vient de l'exclusif
l'exclusif c'est quand on vous a dit oui
vous appartenez à la démocratie mais non
ça vous l'aurais pas non non d'accord
les études où ils n'ont même pas la
timbale pas les maths pas ceux ci
passait là par exemple il y aurait bien
d'autres exemples
nous avons en deux siècles fait tout un
travail qui est de demandes de droit et
de subversion de ce qu'il nous manquait
et ce travail que je dis nous tout d'un
coup ce travail est un travail qui est
logiquement passé par des subversions
des moeurs il n'est pas interdit de
passer le baccalauréat a dit julie
daubié en 1860 alors je peux le passé
mais surtout de aussi de demandes de loi
il fallait rattraper cette exclusion qui
a été la nôtre au lendemain de la
révolution parle de l'ucla français le
rattrape et comment par les droits
civils par les droits politiques par les
droits économiques qui sont venus
surtout beaucoup de l'union européenne
et des directives européennes et par les
droits familiaux
c'est à dire introduire de l'égalité par
tous les penseurs du contrat social
avait bien compris
rousseau et d'autres qu'il ne fallait
pas que l'égalité entre dans la famille
l'égalité est rentré dans la famille et
ça depuis 30 40 ans partage de
l'autorité et c'est donc nous avons
accompli un cycle de droit
ce cycle de droit je vais dire qu'il est
achevée bien que nous ayons besoin
d'amélioration des lois de fabrication
éventuellement d'une loi de plus je vous
dis ça par rapport à l'événement que
nous sommes en train de vivre
ce n'est pas une loi de plus qui va
changer complètement les choses donc
améliorons les lois rajoute encore
quelques lois mais nous avons obtenu un
certain nombre de lois et quelque chose
d'autre se passe une autre histoire
commence et c'est pour ça que moi
j'analyse je ne serai pas je ne ferai
pas l'accord pour tout le monde
tout le monde ne sera pas d'accord avec
moi j'analyse la lutte contre les images
la lutte contre les stéréotypes comme
une prise de conscience une conscience
aiguë de ce que les lois
ça ne change pas le réel c'est ça qui
s'est passé au début des années 2000 les
lois ne changent pas le réel c'est à
dire l aide à changer le réel
je pourrais disserter sur ce que la loi
sur la parité fabrique bien sûr le des
pénalisations de l'avortement etc etc je
peux le faire mais on sait très bien que
les lois pour l'égalité économique
transforme si peu le pourcentage salue
la journée d'aujourd'hui nous commençons
à travailler gratuitement jusqu'à noël
donc les lois sur l'égalité économique
ne font pas l'égalité économique donc
d'autres d'autres d'autres stratégies
que nous avons déjà employé depuis deux
siècles mais qui deviennent d'autant
plus importante aujourd'hui qu'elles
sont à la suite de cette répartition de
l'égalité dans tous les domaines donc
pas égalité réalisez vous entendez bien
l'égalité formelle
donc ce réel on peut lutter contre les
images on peut changer l'éducation on
peut faire tout ça mais ce qui se passe
en fait 21e siècle c'est la perception
que le corps des femmes est l'enjeu
pourquoi c'est l'enjeu le corps des
femmes parce qu'il part dans deux
directions très précises en ce siècle
d'une part tout le sexe reproducteurs
tout ce qui est effectivement
reproduction tout les moyens de
reproduction possible toutes les
disputes et tous les débats et toutes
les fabrications de filiation que nous
pouvons faire à travers cette
modification de la fabrication de la
reproduction et d'autre part les
violences sexuelles
je rappelle que les violences sexuelles
que nous connaissons sur ces deux
siècles quand les femmes se battent pour
le droit au divorce au 19e siècle qui
avait été autorisé plus interdite par la
révolution c'est parce que là il ya une
violence intrafamiliale quand on se bat
pour la contraception avortement
c'est parce que notre corps nous
appartient et nous sommes dans une
logique encore qui est d'une logique
privée
là ce qui se passe c'est que c'est le
corps devient l'enjeu public en ce 21ème
siècle
si le corps devient l'enjeu public ça va
pas se régler seulement avec la question
des lois et c'est assez passionnant
alors c'est passionnant du côté de la
production mais je vais le prendre
surtout du côté de la question des
violences
souvenez vous la question des violences
à l'encontre des femmes
bien sûr la loi a changé en 81 ici en
france le viol est devenu un crime ce
n'était qu'un des 10 j'ai participé à
cette lutte là cette lutte là de passer
de délit a crime
ce qui fait que le viol passe maintenant
en incise quand la plainte arrive
jusqu'à en tout cas cette possibilité là
nous avons bien là la perception de la
violence mais là encore aller individuel
depuis 95 depuis la conférence de l'onu
depuis un certain nombre de prises de
conscience de programme et ses
internationaux européens qui sont quand
même beaucoup lié à la question
européenne désolé de n'avoir pas le
temps de le dire mais il se trouve que
j'ai fais une parenthèse européenne
comme député il ya quinzaine d'années et
je les ai suivis de très près a définit
le harcèlement les lois françaises sur
la transcription des directives
européennes
la dernière loi qui dissocie harcèlement
liées au sexe et harcèlement sexuel
vient de l'union européenne et pourquoi
ces nouveaux ce qui m'intéresse pour
dire que c'est nouveau c'est que
simplement c'est ce qui permet de dire
que le corps des femmes est à la
disposition des hommes c'est le
soubassement du contrat social le
soubassement du contrat social c'est ce
que une philosophe américaine appelle
britannique et américaine appelle le
contrat sexuelle c'est ce qu'il dit a su
le contrat social en implicite on parler
d'un pic si tout à l'heure oui il y as
implicite ce corsaire est à la
disposition plus que le patriarcat avec
le droit du père etc tout ça d'accord
mais en fait ce qui se passe avec le
contrat social d'où la notion de
consentement qui si importante et si
cette notion de consentement est si
importante c'est parce que vient là une
sorte de difficultés à définir le
consentement je me suis trouvée mais et
je terminerai là dessus sur ce un hasard
extraordinaire qu'un livre que j'ai
écrit à 10 ans s'appelle du consentement
j'avais écrit pour analyser c'est ça
aussi la deuxième proposition
philosophique trouver les bons concepts
les bons mots pour analyser une
situation et cette situation c'était
celle de porter le foulard ou de se
prostituer
qui dit mais puisque elle consent où est
le problème
main et moi je me suis dit l'on me
demandait alors vous êtes pour la
prostitution pour le voile contre ces
nids j'ai pas donner mon opinion
en revanche je veux construire le
problème construire le problème c'est je
reprends larmes des expressions telles
que gilles deleuze a pu le faire c'est
trouver le bon mot je me suis rendu
compte que le mot de consentement était
le bon bout mais pas pour dire ce
consentement individuel c'est un bon ou
un mauvais consentement pour se demander
si l'addition des consentements
ça fait un consentement politique ça
fait le monde de demain et j'ai donc
écrit ce livre là dessus c'était il ya
une dizaine d'années il se trouve qu'il
est réédité mis en librairie il ya dix
jours
vous imaginez en pleine affaire avec un
épilogue comme avait demandé d'écrire il
ya six mois et qui s'appelle et le refus
de consentir non pas dire non
individuellement mais le refus de
consentir c'est à dire comme positions
politiques position collective position
commune car vous aurez remarqué que ce
qui se passe de l' affaire dsk à la
ferraille nine c'est que d'une histoire
genre 19e siècle nous sommes passés à
des histoires collectives qui donc entre
dans l'espace public et je crois qu'on
nous avait demandé de venir ce soir pour
parler de l'égalité dans l'espace public
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]